novembre est le mois de la littératie
financière et plusieurs organisations
offrent des services des produits des
cours pour vous aider à mieux comprendre
les finances c'est le cas de l'ordre des
comptables professionnels agréés du
québec et l'association des
bibliothèques publiques du québec qui
propose 50 ateliers de formation dans
les bibliothèques tout au cours du mois
et c'est le cas aussi de la fondation
canadienne d'éducation économique qui
s'associe à la banque nationale pour
offrir des ateliers financiers lucie
blanchet et première vice-présidente à
la direction particulier et expérience
client à la banque nationale bonsoir
madame nos chers
d'abord quand on on parle de cette
expression littératie financière ça veut
dire quoi
alors des fois ça peut paraître ingrat
en termes simplement pour dire que c'est
l'éducation financière c'est une
dénomination qu'on utilise souvent ce
qui concerne la finance personnelle donc
on parle pas ici de comprendre les
grandes théories des marchés financiers
mais vraiment la finance la gestion des
finances personnes la gestion des
finances personnelles et il ya un
problème la tuer ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens dans les sociétés qui ont du mal à
gérer leurs finances personnelles
en fait il ya un besoin et plusieurs
études qui ont été faites là dessus
plusieurs statistiques qui circulent
mais celle que l'on à laquelle on peut
le plus le plus souvent s'associer
c'était à peu près 40% des gens qui ont
peu ou pas de connaissances en finance
de base finances personnelles puis
il est très très étroit aussi entre la
santé financière et la santé en général
et la santé mentale et via des études
qui ont été faites de ce côté là puis ça
reste très souvent qui après 40 % de la
population qui on donne importante de
stress campion y con quand ça concerne
la gestion de leur tenue oui mais je
pense que l'argent est probablement le
premier stressant dans la population
quand on en a pas ou quand on a
l'impression que la prochaine paye et
est absolument vital ça peut créer
énormément de stress café alors le sujet
déborde largement voulons associer à la
santé mentale et la santé physiquement
sur un besoin de société si une bonne
comme la vôtre s'associe à une fondation
comme cela pour offrir des ateliers puis
on va en parler dans un instant est-ce
que c'est dire qu'il ya un problème
d'éducation au québec au canada et que
les écoles remplissent bien leur rôle en
termes d'éducation économique et
financière je pense qu'il ya toujours
des progrès que l'on peut faire de ce
côté là en travaillant avec la fondation
l'opportunité c'est que la fondation est
très très près aussi de chacun des
ministères d'éducation dans toutes les
provinces canadiennes
il travaille aussi très très proche des
commissions scolaires
et puis clairement aussi du côté
éducation c il ya un besoin qui ressent
aussi de ce côté là puis à prendre la
fondation ça peut justement mère et d
appuyer avec du contenu supplémentaire
qui est différent du contenu auquel on
est habitué normalement nous croient
comme d'éducation spectre actionnaires
et donc d'où vient ce partenariat avec
la fondation est en fait c'est un
travail de plusieurs mois dans lesquels
je me suis investi personnellement on a
cogné à plusieurs portes et la formation
s'est avéré vraiment pour nous le
partenaire idéal parce que d'abord ils
sont installés et très très crédible
dans ce créneau là depuis 1974
c'est un organisme à but non lucratif
aussi et puis par le modèle d'affaires
et travaille avec des partenaires du
privé très très régulièrement pour venir
les aider à appuyer financements acquis
pour mettre en oeuvre les initiatives
qu'ils ont besoin
alors ces deux c'est de là qu'est venu
le partenariat et vous me disiez que
c'est aussi un intérêt personnel vous
disiez je savais en entrevue que
justement vous allez donner des cours
dans les bibliothèques comme un retard
ça je suis content malgré deux
formations un gm
mieux que je dirais un glossy donc à
travers mon parcours professionnel j'ai
jugé la can ont vraiment été témoin de
plusieurs situations qui font en sorte
que souvent c'est un manque de
connaissances au départ qui fait que les
gens n'ont pas confiance en leur
capacité à gérer leurs finances et donc
je vous offrir ça c'est les ateliers que
vous offrez comment ça fonctionne alors
notre programme quand on va commencer à
regarder le sujet le programme est très
très vaste donc il fallait se concentrer
sur quelques renault avait d'abord
travaillé donc on s'est concentré sur
trois créneaux principaux les deux
premiers sont ralliés plus haut à la
population des jeunes parce que l'on
considère que c'est important de faire
du développement de connaissances et
comme dans les habitudes alimentaires
comment ces jeunes avec des bonnes
habitudes alimentaires c'est plus facile
qu'elle ait changé
plus tard dans sa vie même principe de
ce côté là alors on a un programme qui
qui va dédier pour nous étudiants du
secondaire puis un programme aussi pour
les étudiants de collégiens et
universités les questions en de ces deux
populations là même si c'est des jeunes
sont très différentes
cégep universités comment jean faire
face à mes prêts étudiants quel comment
ça fonctionne pour mes premières peines
et kwame véhicule de placement simple
que je peux comprendre et cetera
les gens au niveau secondaire c'est des
éléments plus de base c'est quoi un taux
d'intérêt
après un tel que je paie et fréquence
régulière versus de marge 2010 que je
paye jamais l'islam naissant avec le jeu
les jeunes au second life où que ce soit
le funk par cette panne maintien qui est
qui peu avant de faire leurs fans au
départ en retraite arrive donc amené
sous forme de jeux aux cégeps
universités avec plus de forme
d'ateliers avec des vrais cas
pour les amener dans l'action sur les
situations que même le troisième volet
de notre programme c'est pour nos
nouveaux arrivants oui qui représente
une population importante de haut niveau
et démographique au québec est en
croissance au canada aussi puis eux ils
font face un sou vaillant des
connaissances mais ils font face à un
nouveau système financier qui est
différent leur pays d'origine chaque
l'idée c'est d'être capable de les
intégrer le plus rapidement possible en
lever ce stress cela qu'ils peuvent
avoir en plus déjà du stress qu'ils ont
21 nouvelles arrivées parler de
développement des connaissances mais je
suis obligé de vous poser la question
est-ce que c'est aussi pour la banque
nationale du développement d'affaires
que de s'adresser comme ça des étudiants
des nouveaux arrivants je dirais
indirectement parce que tout ce qu'on
fait avec la fondation est il vraiment
dans une optique de à but non lucratif
le matériel est disponible pour les
audiences à travers la fondation
maintenant il ya du matériel qu'on
pourrait développer avec la fondation
que l'on pourra mettre disponibles nous
sommes au type b 6 points sert bien sûr
ou auprès de nos employés pour être
indisponible nos clients mais on va
toujours s'entendre sur ce sujet là avec
la fondation parce qu'on développe se
conclure avec eux pour avoir accès aux
ateliers on va sur le site web
mais ça dépend des audiences donc le
contenu que la fondation et nous allons
contenir de mettre sur notre site à nous
oui il va disponible sur notre site web
au départ contre les ateliers ton grand
père au niveau du secondaire typiquement
avec la fondation ce qu'on a contenu
c'était à travers sous forme de jeu les
parents pourront aussi accéder mais ça
va être beaucoup attendre les programmes
que la formation va mettre en place avec
les commissions scolaires très bien
madame blanche et merci beaucoup
d'opportunités